it's vital the vigo family often looks
through their oldest daughter's photos
from the United States she was there
five years ago now her younger sister
wants to go there too she set to leave
in August the 15 year old will spend a
year with a host family we ask if she's
excited certainly after all they aren't
my real family and it's something new
from you help us noise so far alia Vogel
only knows her host family from emails
and they've exchanged photos as well
yeah I from caffeine fun definitely
looking forward to meeting my family
agencies like I yuasa in tracks take
care of finding the right host family
and schools both sisters use this
company to arrange their year abroad
it's Berlin headquarters employs around
40 people to take care of applicants the
u.s. New Zealand and Australia are among
the most popular destinations the
machines become increasingly difficult
the schools have higher demands because
they've been inundated with exchange
students and not just from Germany they
come from all over the world so the
schools have changed the criteria tansel
Tina it takes more than good grades to
apply for a year abroad students need to
be very fluent in the language of their
host country around 18,000 secondary and
university students from Germany went
abroad last year but a man for studying
internships and vacation jobs abroad has
been soaring a private school costs
between 7,000 and 20,000 euros that
includes the agency's fees
v Alice Wow honestly will I be advised
how good in detail will the responses to
my questions and needs be and how did
the organization's deal with problems
when they arise that can never be ruled
out before I give us money I'll
schließen can vivitar matunga gangs
Leia's older sister had a difficult
start during her stay in the US and had
to seek a new host family on her own her
mother hopes Alejo will adjust well the
most difficult part will be to say
goodbye shirt always another I'm going
to be sad but we'll stay in touch